I thought vulnerability was a repellent
it turns out it's the world's greatest
magnet we've been hardwired to believe
that people will be drawn to us if we
are perfect that's the great lie it's
the opposite completely it brings
everybody to you if you think about
what's in greatest Supply in the world
it's the antithesis of vulnerability
it's filtering your life and showing you
know the best parts of your life and
that you're successful and imperfect and
all of those things that's the thing
that's in greatest Supply the thing
that's in highest demand though is the
thing that we can relate to in the 99 of
Our Lives when someone shares their
struggle it increases oxytocin levels in
us and we feel more connected to them
and it is win-win